You know, I live in New York
City and New York City can be completely overwhelming.
So the other day I was feeling kind of stressed
out. And I decided that I was just going to forget about life for a
while and go
downtown and get a piece of cake.
Do you guys ever have one of those days when it just seems like a piece of cake
is going to make everything so much better?
So I headed down to The Magnolia Bakery.
And I'm standing there in line and I start to relax 'cause I think about this guy that I met
recently in the city. I didn't even know him, he just came right up to me in the street.
And he said, "I'd like to give you a piece of advice." And I said, "Sure."
Because, you know, I'm always up for
good advice. And, uh, he said, "You look
really stressed out. You should pick three things you can do
really well. Every day.
And then just let the rest go."
And I thought that was fantastic advice for anyone living in any big city.
Pick three things you can do really well every day. And then let the rest go.
But I thought about it and I remembered.
That guy didn't have any
teeth. [audience laughter]
So I guess "Brush my teeth" didn't make his top 3 list
very often.
But I'm standing there in line at
the bakery and I'm saying this mantra to myself that I made up,
that I say when I'm feeling kind of down. And I want to share it
with you tonight. It goes like this.
You close your eyes. You take a deep
breath, and you say, "May I feel like I feel
when I'm about to eat cake."
And you do! You think "cake!" like you might
get some, and you feel better! It works every single time.
And I'm standing there at
the bakery and I'm almost to the counter, when my cell phone rings. It's
my friend, Karen.
She's down south. She's just been dumped by her boyfriend. She
was dating a gay Elvis
impersonator. Now, I knew he was
gay, and so did everybody else. Only
she didn't.
And, you know, I- I realize it's
so strange how sometimes, we can fall in love with
people, and we can barely even see them.
And I thought that "impersonator" should have tipped her off a little
bit. But I could see the Elvis part would kind of throw
you. [audience laughter]
And I said to her, "Karen, Karen, it's OK, it's OK, you know, it's gonna get better, and
these things happen for a reason." But I realize how difficult that must be to hear
when the Elvis you thought you knew and
loved turned out to be totally queer."
He left her a note on the pillow that said,
"I've fallen in love with a man. I'm flying back to New
York. Thank you very much. Good night."
And I knew right then what I had to
do: I had to go south. I had to see my friend.
So about a week later I booked a ticket to
Georgia and I flew south.
And when I got out of the plane,
it just felt so good to get out of the city for a
while, and I always have this kind of yen for the South anyway, because
I keep having this recurring dream that I'm this beautiful
black woman down south and I'm sitting on my back porch
braiding my daughter's hair.
We're
looking out, watching the fireflies fade into the dusk.
And then I wake up. And I can't tell if that's, like, a past life,
Or if that's just every gay
man's fantasy.
But at the same time, I do believe there is a beautiful black woman down south.
She's sitting on her back porch, braiding her daughter's hair. They're looking
out watching the fireflies fade into the dusk. And she leans over and
she says, "Honey, I keep having this strange
dream." [audience laughter]
I'm a gay man, I'm living in New York City, I'm walking with
crutches.
And I'm eating a piece of
cake. [audience laughter]
Do you think that's real, or is that just every black woman's
fantasy?"
So the plane touches down in Georgia. And I want to get
my friend Karen
a gift. So I go into the airport, and go to the bookshop. And I walk straight to
the self-help section. Because that is the perfect place to start
post-gay-Elvis-impersonator
breakup.
And I'm standing there looking through the
books and I come across that book, "Heal Your Body" by Louise Hay.
And I'm flipping through it, looking up things like lower back pain and canker sores.
But then I look up cerebral palsy. And it's in there. And
it says, "Cerebral Palsy:
Brought to this earth To heal the family with one
sweeping gesture of love." Brought to this earth
to heal the family with one sweeping gesture of love?
The words kind of glared off the Page at me and I threw the book
down and I thought, "You know, I don't really want that job!"
I mean, I-I'm just trying to have a
life. Fuck Louise Hay, man.
Fuck Louise Hay."
Which is a very useful mantra, by the way.
[audience laughter] And I've
used it
many times since. And I don't mean to
imply that the people down south were in any way overly conservative. But I did notice
that a lot of the books on Judaism were in the
occult section.
So I just decided to go. And when I got to my
friend Karen's house she was doing kind of bad and I said, "Come on. Let's go out. Let's go for a ride."
And we got in the car, and we drove for hours. And the amazing thing about
being down south
is that it seems like--to me, anyway--that if you drive just far enough,
there aren't that many houses anymore. There's just these soft green rolling hills.
and the sun is shining. But there are these little churches. Everywhere.
And they have these marquees out front with the most amazing sayings on them.
And one of them said, "We love you. And there is nothing you can do
about it"
[audience laughter] So we decided to check
that out. [audience laughter] So we wa-
So we
walked into the church and it was a Southern Baptist Televangelist church.
And when we walk in, cameras are on cranes, swinging around the room. And the minister is up
there preaching. How Christ is gonna come down and wipe the blood of
the sinners from the seat of judgment.
And I didn't really understand him.
I just heard "spilling of the blood of sinners" as I was walking in. And I
was sure he was talking about me.
And we sat down in the front pew, the only place left
open. And right then, this woman and a couple of other men from the
church come up to me. And she says, "Can I ask you a question?"
And I said, "Sure."
And she said, "Are you
comfortable?" And I said, "Well,
it's a little hot in
"here."
And she said, "No, are you comfortable living in that body?" "Yeah,
"You know what, I -"
know what, I am, so just move along.
But
she and the other men took me to where the minister was preaching,
and he grabbed my head. And he said, "I want you to get the Devil out of
your body, I want you to throw down those canes and walk, I want you to get the devil out of your body, I want you to throw down those canes and walk,
I want you to get the devil out of your body." And then, palm flat, smacked me in
And then palm-flat, smacked me in the middle of the forehead. [laughter] But instead of
But instead of falling over, I just sort of leaned back, and then I came
up again. And he actually seemed kind of mad.
Like I wasn't working with him. So
he knelt down on
his knees in front of me, and he starts rubbing my
legs. And he says, "I want you to get to the devil out of your legs, get the devil out of your legs," and
oh my God, guess what happened.
I got an erection.
[laughter]
Which even for me is completely out of control.
And I'm looking down, thinking, "Well, I'm certainly going to go to Hell now."
And he's down there rubbing my legs, "Get the Devil out of your legs! Get the Devil out of your legs!"
I'm thinking, "Sir, that's not where the Devil is
right now."
And you know, the
funny thing is, if I can actually put down these canes and stand on
my own and walk a
few steps. Not very far.
But you guys. I don't know if it was the cameras or the
pressure, but I just didn't know how to get out of it.
So
I put down one cane.
And then I put down the other. And for just a second,
I stood up.
And the congregation starts
freaking out, and the minister looks at me, like, "Oh, my God!
I actually did it."
And you know, I always did sort of want to be on T.V.
I just never thought it would happen that way.
Which just goes to show, the Lord does indeed work in mysterious
ways. But you know, while it was happening,
while I was in the middle of it, I wanted to
say "stop". Wait, I mean
"I'm OK. Who are you to decided that I need to be healed of this?"
of this? Did you make me less
neurotic? Can you get me a better job?  How about the perfect boyfriend?
But not this.
This just isn't at the top of my
list."
But I wasn't brave, and I didn't tell him.
And then for just a second I thought, "What if he really
did have the ability to heal people,
and
somehow, it didn't happen.
Because I was the most cynical one in the room.
Right then my friend Karen comes up and she grabs me by the shoulder and she says, "Come
on, let's get out of here."
And we get in the car, and we drive in silence for hours.
And we end up back in Athens, Georgia,
and we're sitting there at the Grit Restaurant.
And my friend Karen's across from me with her triple-layer white sponge
cake with chocolate frosting. And I have my German
Chocolate cake. And as I sink my fork down through the layers, I
think, "This is what it's about." You
know? These are the moments where we find our faith
the joy of the
anticipation of the moment. Because there will always
be fantasies about being someone else. And there will always be people who want
to heal you,
So they can feel better.
And there will always be a gay Elvis impersonator
who will break your heart. So
I sit back and I open wide. And I
say, "May I
feel like I feel when I'm about to eat cake."
[applause]